welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
were breaking down the big bad of
Resident Evil 3 that is the nemesis
though his name has been dropped from
the title of the game he still makes a
huge impact throughout it's 3 to 5 hour
runtime and he's as fascinating today as
he was all the way back in 1999
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the origins of the Nemesis
and all the bits of info that you need
to know about him there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to complete the game yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly recommend that he turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy it
without the way thank you for clicking
this and let's get into our breakdown of
the Nemesis
okay so nemesis on the surface it may
seem like he just wanders around
repeating the same thing over and over
like some deranged Pokemon who's got his
nose all bent out of shape but there's
actually a lot going on with the
character to discuss him we have to
travel all the way back to the 19th
century where the progenitor virus was
first discovered by Henry Travis in West
Africa his work was well documented and
later picked up in the 1960s by Oswald
Spencer and Edward Ashford you may
recognize these names if you're fans of
the series especially the former and
Spencer mansion from re1 and Spencer
Hospital from her III would go on to be
named after him they discovered that the
progenitor virus could be drawn from a
specific plant by placing into damp and
dim conditions such as a cave this would
cause it to produce the virus which the
company umbrella could then mutate and
re-engineer into specific strains though
the t-virus was the most predominant of
these the g-virus was later created an
umbrella went through multiple changes
over the years through testing their
formulas and procedures the t-virus
though useful was thought to be too
chaotic because it created monsters with
subpar intelligence that were too
difficult to control though hunters
advanced on this slightly and they did
have some intelligence this was limited
solely to 30 commands and thus they did
not match the human-like intelligence
that the company was seeking Umbrella
wish to create mutations that were fully
cognitive and ones that could follow
orders
so they spent countless amounts of money
on their R&D in order to refine that
process nemesis is the way that he is
purely because he was created through
the multiple failings that came before
in which umbrella learned from their
mistakes and improved their mutations
whether it's Lisa Trevor the hunters
tyrant or mr. X they were all stepping
stones on the chain of evolution to get
to the Nemesis the creature is named
after the goddess of vengeance in Greek
mythology and it has made several
terrifying appearances in video games of
the heirs the Nemesis t-type itself was
created in umbrellas Europe number six
laboratory in September 1998 the
corporation had the goal of selling it
to the US Army and the creature is the
culmination of several decades of work
when first attempting to make bio
weapons the biggest problem initially
was that the beasts were too difficult
to control cell they developed a
parasitic organism that would latch onto
the brain of the monster and this would
hijack their systems and allow for them
to be managed human test subjects were
used which were then advanced into
tyrant models and there were several
stages of the process before Umbrella
locked it down the scientists realized
that when the any a parasite was placed
within a t 103 host that the nemesis
creature would spawn from this and his
highly intelligent being would be an
asset in their arsenal though a number
of Nemesis creatures were created
predominantly in this video were going
to be focusing on the one from the game
however it should be noted that in the
lab two of the t types developed ego and
self-awareness and did try to escape the
grounds now who the nemesis mutated from
is still up in the air however there are
a number of theories from the film
depictions of the character it's often
romanticized that he's tied directly to
stars and the main cast of characters
themselves whilst he could quite easily
be a regular unknown I think my favorite
theory is that it is Billy Cohen from
Resident Evil 0 we learn in Resident
Evil 0 that Wesker and William Birkin
were both looking over belly and he's
never returned to the series after the
parting ways with Rebecca chambers at
the end of the game Rebecca would go on
to the mansion as we learned and Billie
fled into the forest which we also know
was full of monsters and likely the
watchful eyes of umbrella chambers did
file a false report upon returning to
Raccoon City that stated Cohen was dead
and that they had been forced to leave
his body behind and since then he's
completely disappeared off the face of
the earth Wesker has been known to use
people in his sick experiments and he's
often kept files on them due to barely
surviving the incident his combat skills
and being presumed dead he would make
the perfect person to be experimented on
I believe that when Billy fled into the
forest he was picked up by the forces of
umbrella and this is why we've never
seen him again from here he was
transformed into the Nemesis and as they
say the rest is history again this is
not going to
but I do enjoy when things are tied
together like that and in my head that's
the way it played out now depending on
which game you play depends on what
story beats happened with the character
as the remake and original differ at
several points however the overarching
storyline is pretty much the same after
the virus outbreak in Raccoon City
caused by events that we learn about in
Resident Evil 2 umbrella ship the
Nemesis out with one mission to wipe out
all members of stars this is because
they wanted to bring an end to their
investigations and attempts to oust the
company moles and agents within their
organization were instructed to record
the combat skills of the creature in
order to verify its application in
military usage and this was carried out
predominantly by nicolai umbrella wanted
to demonstrate its ability to recognize
and track specific targets it was also
given access to a number of weapons
including a rocket launcher and in later
versions of flamethrower this would
showcase its ability to handle firearms
and overall the entire fall of Raccoon
City was seen by umbrella as an
opportunity to collect data on their
next product now depending on what
version you play nemesis was successful
in wiping out certain members of stars
it did kill Brad Vickers in the original
however this was changed for the remake
which personally I didn't like just
because then I think it makes the
creature look like it wasn't that good
in the end but in both versions of the
game and the Nemesis talked Jill
Valentine and attacked her every
opportunity
however Jill managed to best at several
times and the parasite began to secrete
chemicals into the body that caused it
to mutate further this made it harder
better faster Daft Punk and it
eventually caught up to Jill and
infected her with the t-virus
fortunately Jill's a lie Carlos was able
to save her and in the original the
monster then turned its attention to him
whilst she recovered when Jill was back
on her feet the creature went back to
hunting her on Carlos in the original
game they made their way to umbrellas
incineration disposal plant whereas in
the remake they ventured to the nest to
both had facilities for dumping bio
waste and in the depths of the location
Jill oh and head to head with the Beast
after beating it another time it mutated
into a hideous gigantic blob and Jill
was able to find
vanquish it using an experimental rail
cannon that completely decimated it in
the remake this wiped it out but in the
original gel finish it off with a couple
more Magnum blasts gel and Carlos made
their escape and were rescued by a
helicopter whilst the city and the
remains of the creature were completely
wiped out
this ended the story of the monster
though it wouldn't be the last time that
we saw it now before we get into the
rest of the video I just wanna let you
know we're giving away a free copy of
the Star Wars Skywalker saga box set to
one random subscriber all you have to do
to be in when the chance of winning is
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the game in
the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
April and the cell be shipped out from
the inter baguettes the prize it's the
best of luck that everyone who takes
part now though nemesis was killed in
the destruction of Raccoon City he's
also made other appearances in video
games
if a player failed to complete a level
within the time limit on Resident Evil
survivor 2 Code Veronica longest title
ever then the villain would show up and
chase them players could unlock an extra
mode under the right conditions that
would allow them to go face-to-face with
the monster who would be equipped with
the rocket launcher in Resident Evil II
Umbrella Chronicles the game recreated
aspects of our e3 and in that Nemesis
chases Jill throughout it the nemesis
also appears as a playable character and
Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom 3 and Marvel
vs. Capcom infinite in this storyline
he's been captured by MODOK and
reprogrammed to do his bidding
nemesis fights off against Chris
Redfield in the game and makes for a
great character to use the bash the
Hulk's head in with nemesis 2 appears in
Resident Evil operation Raccoon City and
is a key mission which ties back to the
original the game tasks players with
finding a parasite to repair the nemesis
with once they have this they have to
defeat the monster and then inject it
this kind of rat cons a lot of the
original story and actually has players
being the ones that inject the monster
with the parasite that wants to hunt
down the stars this song makes it so
that there were two consciousnesses
within the Beast and the second one was
the one that we faced up against in the
original game now whether you like that
or not it's entirely up to you but that
everything you need to know about the
nemesis it really took me back down
memory lane researching this and I hope
you had a great time watching the video
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the nemesis and if you
enjoyed the remake or not comment below
and let me know and if you like this
video then please give a thumbs up and
make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the ending and post credits
scene which is going to be linked after
this we go over the final few scenes and
discuss the news of Resident Evil 8 so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at Definition
YT click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon
[Music]
[Music]